(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are asking the question,
what are we most looking
forward to in this,
the year that is 2019.
Two thousand and the nineteen.
- Nope, don't say two thousand nineteen.
- Two thousand and nineteen.
- We've left that behind.
- Twenty one nine.
You know, it's so fresh.
I'm so glad to be here experiencing 2019,
to be in the middle of it.
I don't even remember 2018.
It is such a distant memory
that I can't even access.
I can't even imagine being in 2018
and thinking about 2019.
- I remember some things about it,
like capping it off with an
incredible holiday season.
Got to spend it here in Los Angeles.
- First time ever.
- Didn't have any, there was
no interpersonal conflict
between me and my family.
- Me neither.
- Yeah, there's no arguments at all,
the kids seem grateful for everything.
- I'll tell you the presents I'm gonna get
in a little bit and they were perfect.
Like things I didn't know I wanted, I got,
and they weren't only for my benefit,
but for the benefit of society.
- Well this is probably
a good time to tell you.
- And the New Year's Eve party?
- I think this is a great time to tell you
it's still 2018 when we're recording this,
and we have not yet
experienced any of the holiday
festivities, but we're
basically just trying to
make it seem like it went great.
- Yeah so, in the next Ear Biscuit,
I predict that we will
record it in the New Year,
and that we will talk
about and give each other
and you an update on
how our 2018 wound down
in terms of the holiday's
and the New Year's.
And I'm planning to go to Sedona,
I'ma check out some Sedona.
- Sedona, you don't say.
Sedona say.
- By the time this comes out,
I will be back from that,
and then so the next recording,
I'll tell you all about it,
and my gifts that I didn't know
would be so amazing, and New Year's Eve,
and all that jazz.
- Well I'm going to Mexico.
- That's right, but you're
going on a romantic excursion.
- I am, the children are
being left alone at home
to fend for themselves.
You know, 10 and 14, I
feel like that's adequate.
I mean back in the 1800s.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, back in the 1800s, you
could leave a four year old
alone for months, and they
fended for themselves.
They learned how to hunt.
We have Locke access to the car.
He looks old enough to drive,
and the grocery store is
not too far from the house.
He's got a credit card,
he's gonna keep them fed.
- I did believe you for a little bit.
- You thought I was gonna
leave my kids home alone?
- You were very convincing.
- Really?
- I mean I thought we like
expended all of our lies
in the previous bit.
- I got lies for days.
- Well that's true.
- No, but the kids will be taken care of
by a responsible adult, but
they will not be with me,
I'll tell you that right now.
- My compromise, my kids
are gonna be with me,
but we're not doing the RV thing,
which I don't know if I'll regret that.
I'll let you know.
So anyway, we're gonna give you an update
on everything that's
happened, but for now,
we are absolutely in the 2019 mindset.
We've got some things
that we've pulled together
that we know are happening
in the coming year
that boy, when I start
going through this list,
I get excited.
You know, I like having little,
some of it's like little
silly frivolous things
that I can just go ahead
and put on my calender,
with just like some asterisks.
You know, just a little pop to your life,
just a little something
to look forward to.
It could be a movie, it could be an album,
it could be something personal,
or something professional.
We'll get in to all that.
- Yeah, we will get somewhat personal,
but a lot of these things
are things that you're gonna
have an opportunity to enjoy yourself,
if you have access to
an internet connection
and you're not living under a rock.
You'll be able to enjoy
these things as well.
Do you want to go ahead and
talk about some of them?
Right now?
- Yeah, yeah let's get into it.
Yeah I think an easy category
to start with is movies.
I have this, let's see what is this.
I have an app called Flixster?
- I got that app too,
powered by Rotten Tomatoes.
- Not a sponsor, but it gives
all the ratings in there,
but it also tells you when
new movies are coming out,
and you can scroll,
sometimes you can scroll like
months and months and months in advance,
and boy did I find a gem in there.
- Well first of all, before
we get into the specific
movies, I know a lot of
people have, you know,
there's a not insignificant
percentage of people
who when you talk about,
when you start talking
about movies and what you're gonna see,
and it has been reviewed,
then you're like ah,
it didn't get great reviews.
It's only got a so and
so on Rotten Tomatoes,
and then they're like I
don't really go by that.
I go by it, but there's not an,
there's not a small percentage of people
who just ignore what Rotten Tomatoes says,
as if Rotten Tomatoes is one thing.
Rotten Tomatoes is by
definition an aggregate score
of both critics, and
then separately, fans.
- And so submitting yourself to it,
drastically increases your
chances of seeing a good movie.
Feldman, you're upset about this
because you like to
think of yourself as like
an opinionated artist.
- That's why I brought this up.
- Who doesn't want, it's a
betting game that you'll win,
but what will happen is
yeah, you're an individual.
- Well you know why
you can play that game?
You know why you can play that game?
'Cause you don't have children, man.
If you have children, you can't risk that.
- You also don't have taste.
Just kidding.
- You can't risk.
- That's a joke.
A big part of your job is taste.
- No no, no, no, the
reason I'm explaining it
is because the people who have told me
they don't go by Rotten Tomatoes,
talked to me as if Rotten
Tomatoes is just a guy
named Rotten Tomatoes.
Yeah, if like A.O. Scott
was the only person,
shout out to a film critic
that I can think of,
and it might not even be right.
If he was the only one that was on there,
I'm not gonna go by one
critic's recommendation,
but it's an aggregate.
And even though I do
also do the same things
with restaurants and Yelp,
and then people are like,
but yeah, people can
beat the system on Yelp.
Yes they can, and it happens occasionally,
but as a general rule,
if there's a large number of reviews,
it's a pretty accurate
predictor of what kind of
experience you're gonna
have at a restaurant.
There's a reason that these apps exist.
This is not an ad for an app, Flixster,
or Rotten Tomatoes, is just you know,
I think we're of the same
school of thought here.
I'm not gonna waste my time
if it's not certified fresh.
- I mean I didn't provoke the rant.
I don't know who you've been talking to.
Feldman was just looking the other way
and we interpret that as
need a rant fired at him.
- Rant cannon on.
- Star Wars Episode X is coming out.
You know that will be,
I believe that's towards
the end of the year.
Here's the thing, I don't
know because I try to
know so little because
I want to experience it
with not, without being
influenced by anything,
so Episode Nine.
- But do you like to know
at what point in the story
it comes?
- Well I've seen the other ones.
So I mean all I want
to know is what I know
from seeing the other ones.
Which yeah, I'll watch them again.
What's the Kylo and Rey
situation, what are they up to?
They making babies yet?
Hope they're not related
and making babies.
- I'll definitely see it.
- Will Darth Vader come back as a ghost?
- I'm not, you know, I'm just,
I enjoy the films.
I you know, I had a tradition
of taking like my whole
family back in North Carolina
when I was at home for
Christmas, back when they were coming out
every Christmas.
You couldn't get away from them.
I would take everybody to the movie,
but, I don't know, I just can't say that
I'm particularity excited about it.
- I am, I really liked the last one.
I'm not too picky.
I'm just happy when it's done well.
So I'm not gonna mention that Solo movie.
- Oh, so you're extracting
Solo out of the,
you're saying it's like
a blip on the radar,
and you're unblipping it.
- Yeah, don't even hear it.
- I'll tell you what I
am excited about, is.
- But I'm not watching
any, my final point is that
I'm not watching or
listening, no trailers.
If I'm watching another
movie and the trailer
for Star Wars comes on,
I am literally going to
close up every orifice.
Like I'm gonna go into a
tornado drill type situation.
At least, I like, that's
what keeps it special for me.
And my family, they'll
probably have to see them
and they'll get all excited.
I like, we still get
very excited about it.
- They don't abide by the same principle.
- They can't resist, they get mad at me
'cause they want to tell me about it,
they get mad 'cause I'm
like (random noises).
- The movie I'm most
excited about but I'm also
a little bit apprehensive
about, I'm anxious about it,
is Jordan Peele's movie, Us.
This is, you could call
it a follow up to Get Out.
- You shouldn't.
- But here's the thing.
- It has nothing to do with it
except that he's making it, right?
- Well, it has, what it has to do with it,
it is another horror
movie that plays into,
is a commentary on racial issues.
- Oh it is?
- Yeah, so first of all, that's
what made Get Out so great,
right?
Everything about Get
Out made Get Out great,
A, the fact that it was
completely unexpected.
It's like what is this
guy from a comedic duo
suddenly doing making a movie?
It would be like one of
us making a movie that
was good, that's not going to happen.
- Speak for yourself.
And you can't recreate that part of it.
- That unexpected huge
success, 30 million dollar
opening weekend, 100 million
plus dollars gross is like,
he set such a high bar, that
that's a difficult thing,
but it also means he can write
his own check at this point.
But anyway, the thing
that made it great was,
if you haven't seen it please,
even if you're a person
that's like I don't like
horror movies.
I don't like them, I don't like that.
I don't understand why
anyone would want to be
purposely like, around
that negative energy,
like why would you submit
yourself to something
that kind of thing?
Because it just makes me feel triggered
and I don't want to watch it.
- Especially if it's highly
rated on Rotten Tomato.
That guy means nothing to me.
- If Rotten Tomato said that it was good,
then my experience is that
he's wrong and it's bad,
so I'm not going to see it.
It's alright, 2019 is the new Rhett.
Even meaner than 2018.
- And we're not even actually in it.
That's scary.
- I'm just ramping up for it.
Go see it, you're not gonna get hurt.
It's a movie.
It's not even smell-o-vision yet.
It's not even one of
those rides at Disneyland
where all of a sudden you
get sprinkled with water.
That doesn't happen.
It's just, you're in
a seat, it's a screen,
it's just images.
It's not gonna hurt you.
- I wonder if the Twilight Zone movie,
which I don't know if he's
directing or he's producing?
He was producing a number
of movies that I think
are coming out this year as well,
so he's got this backlog.
They were talking, there was one,
maybe it was Us, then it
was the Twilight Zone,
so I don't know which one comes out first.
- But well, I'm sorry, I
keep getting sidetracked.
But it was so unexpected, it was so good,
it was so legitimately scary, suspenseful,
it was well acted, all the
performances was great.
- Us can't be as good.
The surprise element's gone.
- It was funny, and.
- I hope it is but it doesn't have to be.
- It was this very timely
brilliant commentary
on racial issues that, it
was a commentary on racism
in this fresh unexpected way
that actually sort of
highlighted the racism
of white people who don't
realize that they're racist.
Right?
- Everyone's seen the movie.
- No, but what I'm saying is,
I'm just pointing out the
fact, why it was so brilliant,
because it wasn't that
it was just so unexpected
and so great in so many ways,
and then he said that
he has always wanted to,
for a very long period of time,
had in his mind a way
to explore those kinds
of social issues through horror.
And that he had a bunch of ideas lined up,
and Us was the next one he had lined up.
Let me just give you a few details,
because I want you to
get excited about this.
- Oh I'm excited.
I'm afraid, I'm actually
trying to lower the bar
and say success is 75% of Get Out.
- It's coming out March 2019.
It centers around two couples,
one black and one white.
The black couple is played by Winston Duke
from, he played M'Baku in Black Panther
and Lupita Nyong'o is
the woman in that couple.
And the white couple is Elisabeth Moss.
- Oh, she is so white.
- And speaking of white, Tim Heidecker.
- Heidecker, he's white too.
- Tim Heidecker of Tim and Eric.
He plays the boyfriend or
husband, I don't know the.
- I'd forgotten this, and that's amazing.
I mean he took a dramatic turn in a movie
that I didn't see that I read about,
I can't remember what it's called.
- We stood in a very tight
alley with Tim Heidecker
one time for the Mythical Show.
Remember that tight alley?
- Yeah that was, they really
slathered on the awkwardness,
and I could barely take it,
but I didn't crumble.
The Comedy was the name of Tim's movie,
which was ironically titled.
- And not only that, Duke
Nickleson, is Jack Nickleson's
22 year old grandson, is
making his acting debut
in this movie.
- What?
- Yeah, Jack Nickleson's grandson man.
- Duke Nickleson's a great name.
- If you can't get excited about this.
- Sounds like an inventor,
like a Ron Popuo kind of guy.
Like, and now, another
vegetable cutting device
from the mind of Duke Nickleson.
It's also an actor.
- Well anyway, I'm super excited about it.
I do realize that, and I do agree with you
that the chances that, it
can't, it just can't be.
If it was as good as Get Out,
the argument is this.
The argument for those of
you who care about this.
I heard this, I heard Michael
Rapport make this argument
about why Lebron can never
be as good as Jordan.
- Okay.
- And that is because Michael
Jordan changed the game
so significantly, that no one else,
unless they're from a different planet,
can change the game in
the way that Jordan did,
so he literally changed
everything about the game.
All of a sudden, people
had their own shoe,
and people had their own brand,
and he played completely differently.
Like he introduced things
that seemed other worldly
to the game that Lebron
could only add on to.
So in a one on one
match, sure maybe Lebron
would beat Jordan, we don't know.
But he can't.
- I think we do know, but.
- The stage was set for
Jordan to come and make,
talking about another Jordan,
I didn't even mean to say that.
Jordan Peele to make this movie in a way
that he can't replicate, like you said,
the unexpected success.
So now it's just like is
it going to be as good?
So it actually stands a great
chance to be a better movie,
but it has to be twice as good,
which is impossible, right?
In order to be actually better.
- I think about the M.
Night Shyamalan Sixth Sense
being followed up by Unbreakable,
which I really like Unbreakable.
You know, it was kind of a
shame, 'cause I really liked it,
for it to come out after Sixth Sense,
which I haven't seen.
- You're joking right?
Hold on, you haven't seen Sixth Sense?
You're joking, that's a joke.
I know you haven't seen a lot of movies
but you've seen Sixth Sense.
- I missed that one.
- You missed that one?
- It was kind of a Blair
Witch kind of situation.
- No it wasn't.
- Yeah.
- What do you mean by that?
- I don't know why I didn't see it.
I saw Unbreakable though.
I tried to catch up by seeing the next one
and I really liked it.
'Cause you know why I really liked it?
'Cause I hadn't seen Sixth Sense.
- But Sixth Sense didn't
fall in that weird 80s time
when you were in a weird situation,
and I don't understand what was happening.
- I think I was the person
you were making fun of,
it's like this doesn't
seem like, this seems like
a spooky movie, I don't
like those kinds of movies.
- How did I see it?
What year did Sixth
Sense come out, like 98?
- Anyway, I think the advice
is if you haven't seen Get Out,
don't see it before seeing Us.
Watch Us first and love it,
and then go back and watch Get Out second.
That's what you need to do.
That's it.
Alright, we're gonna get,
I got another movie that I'm
super super excited about,
is happening, and then we'll
move on to some other stuff.
- But first we want to
let you know if you didn't
already see it, there's a mug on the table
that says Ear Biscuits on it.
This is the new Ear Biscuits mug.
It's no longer a jar, now it's a mug.
It has a handle, for those
of you who complained about
not having something to
hold on to other than your
loved one, and even
especially if you don't have
a loved one this 2019 to hold on to,
well you can hold on to our mug.
It feels, it's not as soft as a person,
not as warm as a body, but
well actually holds less water,
but it's cheaper.
It's cheaper than like a
subscription to a dating service
that would potentially find a mate.
- And you can get a set of three.
There's this, there's the L
tent mug, and the brand new
Good Mythical Morning official mug.
They work all three together.
They play very well
together for the first time.
- You can pour water or
any liquid from one mug
to the next and then back.
It's a little bit like a magic trip.
- Go to Mythical.Store,
support entertainment
and rep the stuff that you
love, especially if it's us.
- Rep your boys.
I thought that was your line.
Well let me tell you about this.
First of all, I'm not,
I'm just gonna say this
very quickly that at the end of July,
the new Tarantino film, Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood
comes out.
You just can't ignore this
movie because it's got
Brad Pitt, Leonardo DiCaprio,
Margot Robbie, Margot Robbie,
Al Pacino, the late Burt Reynolds, and.
- How did they do that?
- CGI.
No they shot the film before he died.
And drum roll please, Duke
Nickleson, Luke Perry.
- Luke Perry?
- Sideburns.
- Wow we saw him in Mel's
Diner right when we came
to Hollywood and thought we were.
- We were meeting with
a potential manager.
- This is what Hollywood is.
- I'm a Hollywood manager, meet me at the,
meet me at the Mel's Diner,
I can be your manager.
And we go in there and we sit down
and he's like hey, I can be your manager.
You got some talent, you
got some talent boys.
We looked over his shoulder,
he did not become our manager,
so I'm not making fun of,
we don't have a manager.
- 'Cause we don't need one man.
- Look over the shoulder,
and there's Luke Perry.
We're like dang, we're at the wrong table.
- Yeah, we want Luke
Perry to be our manager.
I am excited about that.
I know Tarantino's a little controversial,
but this is supposed to be one of his most
Pulp Fiction like movies
since Pulp Fiction.
- Centered on the cultural backdrop of the
Charles Manson Tate Labianca murders.
We'll see.
Bruce Lee is in the movie.
- It's also controversial because.
- How is Bruce Lee, I mean
someone's playing Bruce Lee
in the movie.
- Yeah, why not.
It's controversial
because it centers around
the Manson murders.
And some of the family members are saying
you can't make a movie about that,
which I don't.
- Who knows.
Who knows what he's going to do,
but he's hard to ignore.
I know, you know.
- That's what I don't understand.
We make movies about historical
murders all the time.
- We should mention, I
mean we should mention It,
chapter two comes out.
- I want to mention it, yeah, I'm excited.
It was my other.
- And then I've got one more.
- Actually It and Get Out
were two of my favorite
movies of 2018, and watched both,
like Locke and I have kind
of become horror movie
buddies and we went to see
It and Get Out together.
And again, the balance
of horror with comedy.
- It was brilliant.
- The way that they.
- I thought it was brilliant.
- And I know a lot of people
said that they weren't
scared by Pennywise, and
again, I don't understand.
Check your pulse man.
But I thought it was great and it was,
as we've already discussed on the podcast,
not even comparable to the original.
The original sucked
compared to the new one.
Don't even get me started on that.
And let me give you a couple of a,
let me give you a couple of tidbits.
Now first of all, in the
book, in the book It,
written by Steven King,
they kind of go between
the original you know.
- Band of kids.
- 1989, when they were kids,
and then is it 27 years
later in 2016 is when it.
Well in the book it was
26 or 27 years between
the two time periods and
whatever, and when he wrote it.
But anyways, the modern day
2016 is when it's supposed
to take place, but they're
going back and kind of
accessing memories, and
so you're seeing the kids
from the original movie,
but then all the kids
grown up played by James McAvoy.
- Well hold on, you just said that.
You kind of mixed the two.
In the book, it's
presented as a flashback,
but in the movie, it was
just presented as kids,
and then at the end,
there's kind of like okay,
now they're gonna get older,
and so now we know in this second movie,
it's them coming back as adults and then,
but we know that there's
flashbacks because.
- Nick Hamilton.
- Is that, that's the bully?
- Yes.
- Who's a mythical beast?
- Nick Hamilton, fan of
the show, mythical beast,
Australian, played the bully.
Just the complete just
horribly awesomely horrible
guy in It.
He's reached out to us,
and we were gonna actually
spend some time with him
when we went to Australia, but he was.
- In Melbourne.
- He was filming It 2, It Chapter Two,
and he couldn't be there,
so we know he's in it.
Hopefully he doesn't get cut.
No but Nick's a great guy,
we hope to actually
meet him at some point,
maybe have him on the show.
- You say he's a great guy.
- He is because he.
- 'Cause he likes us?
- Yeah, yeah, he's got great taste.
That usually translates
to great character.
- And his Twitter messages
were very amicable,
so that's enough for us to
believe he's a good guy.
I do believe he is.
- In order to play a
character that evil that well,
I think you actually have
to be very good, morally,
as a person.
Anyway, the grown ups in the movie,
the grown up kids played by James McAvoy,
Jessica Chastain, Jay Ryan, Bill Hader,
Bill Hader's in it.
Isaiah Mustafa, the
Old Spice guy is in it.
- I met him in a sport's attic,
or some sort of shop that sells shoes.
- And talked to him.
- Talked to him about shoes I think.
- Oh, just about shoes.
You didn't say, you're not on a horse,
or anything like that?
- We've met both Old Spice men.
Met Terry Crews.
- Met Terry Crews.
- As well.
- James Ransone and Andy Bean.
Anyway, I am super excited about it.
Again, it's the kind of thing that.
- I'll definitely see that.
- It's difficult to
imagine it being as good
as the first one.
- It's easier.
- But it is easier.
It's the second half of a story,
it's a second half of a story.
- Right.
- I already said it man,
I said it was horrible.
I said that the 1990 version was horrible.
It's not even watchable, it's garbage.
- Let me tell you,
speaking of not garbage.
Speaking of amazing news, this year,
Tyler Perry's A Madea
Family Funeral is out.
This is the last and it will
be the 10th Madea movie.
I was gonna get you to
guess, but then I forgot.
Would you have guessed
the 10th Madea movie?
- I would of said the 15th.
- Really?
- I definitely would of said
double digits, definitely.
- I was surprised.
So it's the 10th and he said
that it is the last one.
I don't know if she dies,
but I do know I'm not
gonna see it.
I'm just gonna be very,
I'm really looking forward
to it coming out though.
It's just like he needs to put it to bed.
- Have you ever watched one?
- I haven't, maybe that's the problem.
You know what we need to do.
- A marathon.
- We need to catch up, we need to catch up
so we can get on the Madea train.
- Let's watch nine movies in one sitting
and just wear like bags that we pee in.
- Hold on.
- Like literally not
get up the whole time.
- Hold on, I'm legitimately
getting excited about this
so watch out.
I think that we should.
- Rhett and Link's Madea marathon.
- We should watch every, we
should make it into an event
where we watch all nine,
oh my gosh, this is crazy.
- Hold on, but seriously,
we cannot get up.
- No I'm not doing that.
- You have to pee into a stadium, the bag.
- No, I'm not.
- You have to put on
the external catheter.
- I don't want to do
anything that's gonna cause
lasting physical damage.
- One of the things I
was gonna tell you about,
I was gonna save it for
my personal section,
but I'll go ahead and say it.
I'm thinking about wearing
one to work in 2019,
because I keep having to
get up from meetings to pee.
I'm having to pee more
often as I get older,
and so I was just like I'm
gonna wear the fricking thing
that I can just pee right into a bag.
- I feel like this idea makes it worse.
But let's have a constructive
brainstorming moment here.
And hashtag Ear Biscuits.
Let us know, I mean I think this is,
can be a seminal mythical moment in 2019,
leading up to the Madea
premier, which we are going
to attend in person.
We will come straight from
having watched all nine.
Like how, all nine back
to back to back to back
to back to back to back to back to back.
- That's got to be at least 18 hours.
- Yes, and we're going
to be sleep deprived,
we're going to be nutty.
And you apparently will
have stayed in one place.
That's fine for you man.
Like live your world.
- I'm not gonna crap in a bag.
I'll get up for that.
- Let's not leave this.
Let's leave it for now but
let's not leave this idea, okay?
We're gonna catch up.
- Okay, but Tyler Perry has
to acknowledged this though.
I'm not doing it if he
doesn't acknowledge it.
- It's not that I'm happy that it's over,
I was just making a joke at
the Madea series's expense,
but it's really that I've
never watched any of them,
so why would I start with the 10th one?
And we're gonna solve that.
- I've watched bits and pieces of the ones
that have been on television,
and I always find them funny.
You have to go into a certain mode,
and sort of say that this is
the type of comedy, you know.
- There's a reason why he's made 10.
- Yeah, and once you kind of say,
this is not supposed
to be some like, super.
- Art house.
- Sophisticated, this is
low hanging fruit humor man,
and it's really funny.
- Okay.
- It's almost sophisticated
in how broad it is, you know?
- Speaking of catch up,
let's move to television,
and I'm just gonna throw
out two things here.
Stranger Things 3 is coming out.
- Excited about that.
- I never watched all of season two.
- Oh well, that says
something about how excited
you are about season three.
- My family left me in the dust,
and I never went back.
So I got to go back and watch season two
I think before I can watch
season three, but maybe not.
Be like oh that person's
still here, not dead, okay.
- Just watch the recap man.
Just watch the season recap.
- Speaking of catch
up, I do have one more.
- Okay, I've got a TV show
I'm very excited about,
but go ahead.
- Game of Thrones, they
have announced that
probably beginning March,
April, probably be more
specific by the time this comes out,
season eight, which is the final season.
The final six episodes of Game
of Thrones are coming out.
That's pretty huge.
I mean that's, I mean that's
like a cultural phenomenon
coming to a close.
And I just checked before I came in here,
'cause I don't know where
I'm at in the series,
and I'm on episode two of season five.
So I think I'm in trouble here
because once, there's
no way I can catch up
before they start to come out.
And that's really what you need to do,
because at the rate I'm going,
it'll be like another year from now,
and I'll finally be at the very earliest,
I'll be caught up.
I mean it was this time
last year that I started
season one, I went through five seasons,
so it took me a whole year.
- I'm in it.
I'm only like season three.
- You basically gave, you're done.
You're never gonna go back to it.
I read all the books, and
that made it a very satisfying
experience for me to
watch what I've watched.
But my point is, once it's
done and it's all in the can,
I don't think I'll be
motivated to keep watching.
I would love to be able to
catch up and then be a part
of then cultural conversation.
I just don't think I can
do it unless it's all I do
and I'll make use of that
pee bag you're talking about.
- There's no way you can catch up in time,
but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't eventually watch it.
- I just don't think practically I will.
- You'll get too it.
If you're still going at
a snail's pace right now,
it will never end.
- But there's a motivation,
when there's still fresh
episodes coming out,
it's a motivation to
keep trying to catch up.
Is this a personality thing with me?
- Yeah, this is a flaw.
No, to me, this is the
same argument I got into
with my son about watching
recorded sports events.
And so I would say
don't tell me the score,
and don't watch it, and
don't look on the internet,
because when we get home,
we're gonna watch said game.
- What if it's the Super Bowl though?
I mean.
- Super Bowl's a different thing
because I'm not interested,
I don't care about the
results of the Super Bowl.
I just watch the Super Bowl because it's
a cultural phenomenon.
But I'm saying like if
it's a NC State game.
- But what if you did?
I think it needs to be the Super Bowl plus
you cared about the results,
because that really,
that captures more of
the cultural phenomenon
of how they're going to
end this whole thing.
How they're going to wrap it up.
- If you're talking about
the inevitability of it
being spoiled for you by being a part of
conversations in Los Angeles,
that's a different thing.
But I'm talking about
that's not what you said.
What you said was that you're
looking for motivation,
and knowing that it was still
going gave you motivation,
which is again, back to my argument.
'Cause my son said he didn't
want to watch the game
because it had already happened.
And I was like well technically,
what you're seeing on
screen has already happened.
There's a very small delay.
Does that mean that just
because you're not there?
But the experience is still the same.
- It's not the same
because you factor in the
cultural component of
even if it's just talking
with one person about it.
Remember that game that
you watched two weeks ago,
I watched it today, let's talk about it.
I don't really want to talk about it.
- So maybe you got a point.
Because let's say I saved.
- Maybe, yeah.
- Like a state Carolina game,
what if I decided to skip
watching like a state Carolina
game, which is a game that
I care about the outcome of,
and I skipped the one in 2019,
one of their games in 2019,
and I save it for like 2023.
At that point, I'm not invested
because it has no impact
on current proceedings of
the season and the standings,
and there's different players.
So maybe that makes sense.
- I watched Mad Men totally late,
and it was one of my favorite shows.
- It's a story though.
- But I missed out on an added component
that I think.
- The social component.
- But I did get through Mad Men.
- But didn't you want to
see the end of the story?
- But yes.
- So that's different.
- And then for, but I'll
never watch the Sopranos.
So I don't know, it
kind of goes both ways.
- No, you might.
- I won't.
I will never watch, I tried, I started.
I have no one to talk about
this to help keep me going.
- Well what if I started watching it.
Soprano's buddy's.
- Is that our thing, you and me?
The Soprano's?
- Like when we're in a retirement center,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm talking like when
we got a lot of time,
you're gonna be looking
for stuff to binge, man.
- It's gonna feel like
watching a silent film
at that point, if I live
as long as I hope to live.
- TV that I am incredibly excited about,
we have a fun little story about this one.
So you may remember, I've
talked about it before,
I've talked about it on the internet.
2014 movie called What
We Do in the Shadows,
which was, it had Jemaine Clement from
Flight of the Concords and Taika Waititi,
New Zealand based director
who directed Thor,
that's what he's known for,
but he did a lot of
amazing work before that,
continues to do incredible stuff.
They were actually both,
they created and starred
in this movie, which was
a vampire mocumentary,
which was just, and I
remember tweeting about how
when I watched it, it was
my favorite movie of 2014
so far, maybe my favorite movie of 2014.
And again it was one of those
things that's just like,
first of all, these guys are funny.
I find everything that sort of loose group
of New Zealanders do.
- Kiwis.
- Those Kiwis are incredibly funny.
Like I love their sense of humor.
- Yeah, it's a specific dryness.
It's the friendly dryness.
It's like.
- And I just.
- Take a British dryness
but then you make it happy.
- It's one of those things
where every once in while
you like see guys who are doing something
and you kind of know
that they work together
and they are friends,
and I'm just like man,
I would like to be
friends with those guys.
- The movie had a very
labor of love quality,
and I know that all the
sketches and things they,
one of them did themselves,
and was just this very unnecessary,
but very labor of love.
- And it was just hilarious,
and it was not something.
It was a mocumentary.
It's like, who would of thought,
you can't do those anymore.
They're done.
Mocumentaries are done.
All played out, no, it wasn't,
it was incredibly funny,
and they are bringing
that movie back to life
as a television show on
FX, that premiers spring
of this year, 2019.
Now, there's a few things
that are different.
First of all, Jemaine
and Taika are involved.
In fact, the way we found
out about this before it
was public, was we actually
met a PR rep from FX,
who I was like, we were talking about FX
and how much we love FX
and all the shows on there
and she said well,
have you heard of What
We Do in the Shadows?
I was like yes, she's like it's gonna be a
television show.
And the inside information
that I got at the time
which is probably public at this point,
is that Taika was directing
and Jemaine was showrunning.
So basically they are
very involved creatively.
But, a few things to note.
It's not the same group of people.
It's a different time, different place.
- Are there shadows?
- It's still very shadowy.
- Are there vampires?
- I believe so.
Takes place in New York,
specifically Staten Island
and other boroughs.
- Okay.
- Why do you need other boroughs
if you got Staten Island.
All new lead characters,
so nobody from the movie,
not just actors, but I think
it's actually different
characters was my understanding of that.
So Paul Sims, who's the
guy who collaborated
with Flight of the Concords
for their television show
who also is a producer on
Atlanta, is producing it.
So we're talking about a dude who.
Just the people involved are so talented
that it just feels like it has to work,
it has to be great.
Doug Jones, who played the amphibian man
in the Shape of Water, he's
one of the actors in it.
- Oh really.
- I don't know if he plays an amphibian,
I think he's got a range.
I think he can do not amphibious work.
Anyway, sometime in 2019,
that is the television that
I am extremely excited about.
- And I'll be catching up.
I'll just be over here doing my catch up.
Shall we shift to music?
- We shall shift.
- There's not a place,
there's not a repository
on the internet that has a reliable,
these are albums that are coming out.
There's like a wiki entry,
but it's very.
- It's too comprehensive to be useful.
- Well the first thing is
it's not related to the
new album coming out,
'cause that's the thing
that I looked at, and you know,
I didn't find anything specifically
I was too excited about,
honestly.
- Okay, I got something
that's notable, but,
I'll get to it.
- Rolling Stones, they're doing a tour.
How do I know about this, am
I a huge Rolling Stones fan,
no.
I really like the album Tattoo You,
specifically the B side, I'm
Just Waiting on a Friend,
Slave.
- And the reason you like
that is because I happened
to order it on BMG.
- Way back in the day,
I don't know why that's
the Rolling Stone album you got.
- I'm glad it was,
because I've listened to.
- We loved it.
- To me that was their
sweet spot of that like
funk rock that they were
doing that I don't know
what the BPM's were, but
they're a little bit slower.
- Well there was the one big hit on it.
Can't remember which one it was, but it
wasn't Satisfaction but
it was basically like
the one that if you don't
know the Rolling Stones,
you still know it.
- I think it's the
first song on the album,
which I again, I usually
listen to the B side as well.
- But I'm going to their
show at the Rose Bowl
because Britton texted me and he was like,
Rolling Stones, coming to the Rose Bowl.
Let's do it.
I'm like, I don't want
to be a fart on a log
and so I just sat on
the text a little bit,
and then I'm like, well when is it?
And yeah.
- Start me up.
- And then I'm like yeah let's do it.
Now I'm excited about it.
- Well, let me give you
a couple of pointers,
having been to a show at the Rose Bowl,
and a very similar situation
when Mike Edwards came
into town, and he's a big U2 fan.
I'm not not a U2 fan, I
understand and appreciate
what they've done and there's some songs
that I like, but I'm not like, you know.
- Do I need to listen
to the Rolling Stones
and really become like a super fan?
'Cause I can do that.
- Well what I was going
to say is you need to
talk to some people and
try to get down in the
little area next to the stage, which.
- What do you mean?
- You now, you pull some strings.
You talk to some ticket
vendors (mumbling).
- Oh, like say I'm internet
famous and get like a
backstage pass.
- Well you're not gonna
get a backstage pass.
- Not to the Rolling Stones.
- Mick Jagger's not gonna let
you in within 100 feet of him.
But I'm saying you can
get into the VIP area
and be, at the U2 concert,
I was like right next to
the little keystone thing
that Bono comes out on.
- Did you do that instead
of getting a seat?
- I already had tickets.
- I already have tickets.
- And then I was like you
know what I should do,
I should figure out if I
can get some (mumbling).
Well first of all.
- Well maybe I shouldn't have gotten.
- No no, first of all, when
you call who you need to
call in order to try to get
the thing we're talking about.
You got to talk like this.
You got to make them
think they're not actually
doing anything for you,
and it usually works,
and you can get great seats.
And you'll be standing.
You can get Mick Jagger
sweat on your face,
never wash again.
But here's the other thing.
Do not drive.
- Okay, alright.
- Do not drive to the Rose Bowl.
- This is getting titillating isn't it?
Don't drive to the Rose Bowl.
- Because you know how
long Mike and I stayed
in my car after the U2
concert waiting to leave?
- An hour.
- 90 minutes before we moved.
So unless you got a book
on tape or you just want to
go deep in a conversation with Britton,
you need to get a helicopter, you know.
Call up the people and get a helicopter,
right into (mumbling).
- So let me get this straight.
When the show was over, you
went right back to the car
and then you started it up,
but you couldn't get no satisfaction.
- Yeah, motion.
Music I'm not excited about
but I know a lot of people are.
There are four albums
coming out from bands
that some of you may like.
- Tesla?
- First of all, Tesla is
a band, not just a brand.
Megadeath, Skid Row, and Whitesnake.
Hair metal bands all just deciding 2019
is the year of hair metal.
It's back.
It's as bad as ever.
- Something about their
age and their fans,
their sweet spot in their fans age,
it's got to have
something to do with that.
It doesn't have anything to do with me,
I will say that.
- Yeah, I will not be partaking.
- Unless Britton drags
me to some of that too,
I don't know.
I don't think he's into that.
- It's funny because, this is not,
I mean first of all, there
are people who would be like,
you know, you can't put
Megadeath and Whitesnake
in the same category.
I understand that there's probably,
that's probably faux pox for metal heads.
But I just don't know anything about it,
and I don't have any desire to.
But I appreciate again.
- Here's something
you're gonna appreciate.
- If they came down to the Rose Bowl,
I'm not gonna go down to
the VIP section (mumbling).
- You would, no you wouldn't.
I would not, but here's one.
New album coming out from
Hootie and the Blowfish.
Hootie teamed back up with the blowfish.
You know, he had a, he was country.
- He still is country.
- I know his name is Darius
Rucker but he's always
gonna be Hootie to me,
and he never was to anybody officially,
but he's teaming back up with his people.
- Did you know.
- With the blowfish.
- Did you know that Darius
Rucker did a song with Lionel?
Did you did that Lionel did
an album called Tuskegee?
- Yeah.
- That was a collaboration
with a bunch of country
artists in 2016.
- I don't listen to Lionel now,
I listened to the Lionel
that was the sweet,
sweet spot Lionel.
- He does a duet with
Rascal Flatts too on that,
which was, that wasn't
one of my favorite songs,
but you know, when people
like Lionel do things
in the present day, sometimes it has,
especially when they're
collaborating with country stars,
the polish, it's over
polished to the point
that you feel like it
loses a little bit of soul.
But there's some, there's
some really really good songs.
In fact.
- You're showing your dadness.
- No, what does he do?
- There's nothing legit about this.
- Hold on, you haven't listened to it.
You can't judge it man.
- I'm saying, I'm sure it's great.
- What does he do with Darius Rucker.
What song does he do with Darius?
- What you're telling me
is you're going to the
Hootie and the Blowfish, you know,
you're waiting in line for
their album to come out.
It all goes together.
- So yeah, they did Stuck on You together,
and the harmonies are great.
- I'm sure it's great.
- Dude you need to listen to it.
- It's just not relevant.
- Why do I care about that?
- Okay.
- I care about what
sticks to my soul, man,
and Lionel and Darius
Rucker singing Stuck on You
sticks to my soul.
- I don't like artists
covering their own material
decades later, period, period.
Easy like Sunday Morning, leave
it on that Sunday morning.
Don't give me that updated version.
You know, it just doesn't
work, there's a sadness to it.
Even if it sounds great,
I'm like I'm relieved
that Lionel's duet with
Hootie sounds good,
and I think he's still got it,
but I don't want him to cover
his old songs 20 years later.
And here's the thing that I hated,
with streaming music they
can still sneak it in there,
but I think the industry
doesn't allow for it as much
anymore.
I hope I'm right about this, because it,
when an act will release an
album of their greatest hits,
but they've covered so their own songs,
so it's something about
how they can make money
off of it, but it's the
artist covering their own song
decades later.
- That's different, that's
a different category.
That's different.
- I hate that.
- I hate that as well,
but that's different.
- But then people are like,
let me listen to like,
oh you like Lionel, let
me listen to some Lionel.
And they're going on Spotify
and they're listening
to like 2016 Lionel with Hootie.
And they get a totally wrong
impression of how amazing
it is.
- But do you know who
Lionel sings Easy with
on the album?
- Alabama.
- Willie Nelson, man.
- Well okay.
Willie Nelson is an exception.
- But hold on, that's different though.
- Oh my gosh, I just
realized I had a dream about
Willie Nelson last night.
It was you and me, we were
sitting somewhere like
on bleachers, I was sitting
here, you were on my left,
and I was looking at you,
and then I leaned forward.
And who was there?
- Easy like Sunday morning.
- Willie Nelson, Willie
Nelson was like just on the
other side of the, I could of
reached out and touched him
if you weren't in the way.
And you know what, you know what I did?
I leaned over into your ear and I said,
he's a good looking man.
Still got it.
- Well, that's not what he's known for.
- I mean he's really held up well,
those are the three things I've said.
- He got old early, that's
why he held up well.
He looked old at 30.
That's the great thing
about getting old early.
- I'm not saying he's attractive,
I'm saying he looks good.
- He sounds good because
he also sounded old early,
just like Chris Christofferson.
If you sound old early, you
can sound great forever.
- It was thrilling to be
that close to you Mr. Nelson,
in a dream.
And the reason why I
had the dream was 'cause
we have a urinal on the other side,
and when you're peeing in that urinal,
right above that urinal.
- That's my picture.
- There's a portrait of
Willie Nelson staring you
right in the face.
- My wife got me that
and I didn't have a place
to put it up inside.
- Your house.
- My house, because she
was thinking that we would
put it up in the office,
and then she just put it up
over one of the urinals.
- I mean.
- I don't mind, Willie watching me pee.
- Nothing makes me relax my prostate
like staring deep into the
eye holes of Willie Nelson.
- Willie can watch me
and my willy anytime.
- Willie.
- Let's move on to
technology, why don't we?
- Let's do it.
Tesla.
- 5G is coming.
- What does this mean?
I've heard about this, I'm like, you know.
- And I'm not talking about
when you're on your wifi,
and it's like there's a 5G
option, that's bullcrap man.
- Just like you got two
different bands on your router,
and no one ever tells you
which one you're supposed
to connect to.
- 5G is the fifth generation.
- You're making me angry.
I think you're just
really, you've peed in my.
- Peed in your grits?
- In my cornflakes.
Some of your cornflake
has gotten in my bowl.
- 5G is the fifth generation
of wireless technology.
Okay so, obviously you remember 3G,
and then it turned into 4G slash LTE,
and you remember the jump?
You probably don't.
But if you don't remember
the jump from 3G to 4G,
it basically went from
forget about ever watching
video on your phone to, oh,
I'm watching video on my phone.
And you forget that, and
sometimes if you're out
and about, which is definitely
the case in Los Angeles,
because of the mountains
and the weirdness,
you can suddenly find
yourself in a 3G spot,
and it's almost, you don't
even have a phone anymore.
I mean you might be able to text,
you can have a conversation,
but you're not gonna use any data.
- You only have what used to be a phone.
- Right.
The step from 4G to 5G
will be as significant
or more significant.
- So what am I gonna experience?
'Cause it's not video, streaming video.
- Well first of all, the
internet connection will be
ten times as fast.
Okay, ten times as fast as LTE.
Latency will be reduced to a millisecond.
It will be unnoticeable.
So basically this means a whole lot that,
I'm not an expert on this,
but I can read articles
and tell you what they say.
Essentially, it's gonna
do a number of things.
This is sort of the beginning
of the end of their being
a point of reference
for things taking time
over the internet, okay?
So we still live in a world
in which we wait for things.
We see something spinning
on Netflix to load,
et cetera, and this kind of thing.
But this is the beginning
of there being wirelessly
in the air, broadcast everywhere,
accessible to any device
that can tap into it,
not waiting for anything.
Now of course, it's technology,
it's gonna screw up,
you're gonna get frustrated
with it just like any technology.
- Or people will start making things,
like now we're gonna start
streaming 3D environments,
but you're gonna feel like
you can't live without it,
and then you're gonna be
frustrated with it loading.
- Well loading is.
- I don't mean, like holograms.
You're gonna stream holograms.
- Well actually so,
holograms, not so much,
but AR, so augmented
reality, virtual reality,
the fact that we're gonna
get down to wireless
latency being so small, you're
not gonna have a console
to experience.
'Cause basically you have
to have a real world device.
You've got to have like a
phone that you're putting
into a device, you've got
to have like Google glasses.
You've got to have something
that's on your person
that isn't tethered to
something in order to really
be immersed to the world
of, like to bring augmented
reality to the world, we
have to have something
that is out and about,
and it's everywhere.
I can take it to the grocery store,
it's gonna change the way
I interact with everything.
5G is the beginning of that happening.
It's like things are kind of settling,
but it will be that significant.
Also, any technology,
like self driving cars,
autonomous cars, being able
to communicate with each other
and communicate with the
internet in a way that's
fast enough for them to like be reliably
kind of dependent upon this
interconnected network.
That's gonna happen with 5G.
And it's being rolled out,
it's being rolled out
in a number of cities.
Depends on who your carrier is.
But basically you're also not have to have
a cable coming into your house.
You're gonna have a
wireless modem that captures
the 5G and then that modem,
your local wifi is gonna be
broadcast around your house
and to your television and all this stuff.
You're not gonna be drilling
holes into your house.
The cable guy's not gonna
come out and have to go
oh a tree limb fell on your cable
and you're screwed.
That's not gonna happen because
it's all gonna be wireless.
5G man, welcome to the fricking future.
- The thing I found was.
- In selected cities.
- Elon Musk is gonna be sending people
into space, into the
International Space Station
on his space shuttle, the Dragon.
Boeing's working on one too,
they're supposed to have out,
and there's been some unmanned.
Well right now our astronauts
have to hitch a ride
on the Russian shuttles to the
International Space Station.
So NASA has contracted
with SpaceX and Boeing
to have our own shuttle system.
- Well hard do you think it
would be for us to work out
doing our Madea marathon at the
International Space Station?
- Well it's gonna be
much easier this year.
- Elon if you're watching,
I know you're a fan.
If you would like us to
have our Madea marathon
on the International Space Station,
if you feel like you can
pull the right things.
(mumbling)
We will do it.
I'll pee in a bag.
I'll pee out in the open.
Your pee just turns into
a yellow ball in space.
And then you can capture it with a net.
So whatever you want, whatever it takes.
Tyler Perry doesn't even have to be there
if we can do it all on the
International Space Station.
- Elon Musk's cars will have,
will be playing the new Tesla album only.
They've worked out a deal.
- They should work out
a deal, first of all.
- He tweeted this around
Halloween of last year,
that a Tesla will be able to
drive around a parking lot
and find an empty spot, read
signs to confirm it's valid,
and park.
- That's helpful.
- And illegal.
On a state level, they have to create laws
in terms of self driving
cars and stuff like that.
- Laws are for losers.
- You know, so it's like valet.
So it's just one more thing to just like,
maybe I need to get one of those Teslas.
- Maybe you do, man.
You ought to get one,
splurge a little bit.
- Splurge, I just can't bring myself
to do something like that.
I don't know, maybe.
- Jazzercise is going to
be celebrating 50 years.
- Oh now we come to it, the good stuff.
I don't exactly know what Jazzercise is,
because I'm picturing like
Jane Fond in leotards,
my mom used to take me to
the church fellowship hall
and I'd have to sit in
the corner and like color
while she was jumping
around with leg warmers on.
- She was probably doing Jazzercise.
- But she was doing the church version,
and Amy Grant was involved.
- well it's a system, it's a franchise.
Well I don't know if
they do it at churches,
maybe they do, but it is a franchise.
- 50 years though?
- Well let me tell you
a little bit about this,
because when I found
this out, I was excited.
- Is Jane Fonda part of Jazzercise?
- I do not believe so.
It was started by some woman
named like Shepard Misset
or something like that.
So it was started in
1969, hence, 50 years ago.
This is crazy.
By 1984, Jazzercise was
declared the second fastest
growing franchise behind Domino's Pizza.
Did you know this was
happening in the 80s?
- You got to license it to do it.
- Today, the company boasts
83 hundred franchises
in 32 countries, and earns
roughly 100 million dollars
per year.
There's 200,000 customers
dancing and sweating to
Jazzercise choreography each year,
millions of lives, this
is like the press release
from Market Watch.
- This is what they wrote.
- Well it's all true.
You think Jazzercise is gonna lie to you?
Millions of live have been
touched during the company's
50 year history.
Jazzercise, now this is where my ears,
this is where my thighs
started perking up.
Jazzercise will celebrate
their golden anniversary.
Your thighs work in jazz?
- They don't perk up though.
- Mine do, you want to
see my thighs perk up?
- There are things that can get perky,
but the thighs aren't two of them.
- Jazzercise will celebrate
the golden anniversary
with a two day international convention
and party, June 28th through 29th, 2019,
at the San Diego Convention
Center in San Diego.
Over 2,000 people will attend the event
that will both be filled
with dance fitness classes,
live entertainment,
international guest performers,
surprise announcements,
and big reveals about
the brand's future.
We got to play Jazzercise,
we got to play Jazzercise.
What if we could play
Jazzercise, do a concert
at Jazzercise 50th golden anniversary,
and do the Madea marathon there.
- This is gonna be a big year for us.
- Clear your calender Link.
My thighs are gonna be so
perky on June 28th and 29th.
Line up and see them jump.
- The thing that we are doing
is creating more tour dates
for our music and concert extravaganza.
So I mean I don't mean to turn
this into an announcement,
but we're gonna be at
Jazzercise, San Diego.
- Well we got to work out the details.
- Well we're gonna be
in London next month,
February, in association with Vidcon,
we have our own concert,
rhettandlinklive.com,
check on tickets for that.
In April we're gonna be
in Nashville, Saint Louis,
and Columbus, and D.C. Maryland area,
so that's four shows.
The Nashville show's
gonna be at the Rimmen,
which is the birthplace
of the Grand Ole Opry.
Of course then moved,
but like that's the original stage man.
I'm so excited.
Rhettandlinklive.com if
you want to come see us.
- Bringing it in 2019.
- I'm not just trying to make this a plug,
I think that's a big thing
I'm looking forward to in 2019
that we haven't been able
to talk about is like
specific tour dates, and again,
we're looking to do some more.
- Writing music for it, new music coming.
- Yeah, what about personally.
Let's get to some things
that we're looking forward
to personally.
- I'm doing something I've
never done before in 2019.
- This is ambitious man.
When you first told me about
this I was like whoa, really.
- When I looked at the
price tag I was like whoa.
- You're gonna do this?
- I am, I'm doing it, I booked
it today as a matter of fact.
So I am taking the
McLaughlins, or should I say,
the McLaughlins, to Scotland.
I have.
- And how many McLaughlin's
are we talking about?
- Twelve.
- How big is the clan?
- Twelve people.
- Okay so here's the deal.
I've been thinking about
doing this for a while.
I thought that it would be
an unforgettable experience
to take all the people
that I know and love
with the last name
McLaughlin, to the motherland.
- But did you tell any of them that.
- No, I told them when I
knew I was going to do it.
- Yeah, it was in your mind
but you didn't tell them
one day I hope to take you to Scotland.
- No, I've never said that.
I've only thought it.
And first of all, they're very excited.
- How did you tell them?
This was like a gender
reveal or something.
Like you got to make a big deal out of it.
- I just thought that I shouldn't do that.
I didn't want to make a
big, I wanted to make.
- Look at what I'm doing.
- I wanted to make the
big to do just the going.
- Okay, that's admirable.
- So I just told them when I was home,
I told them when I was home
for the state fair, you know,
in October, and they're all very excited.
'Cause I was like, you don't
know if they're gonna be
able to do it, you don't know
what their schedules are.
It has to work out with
when we're gonna be able to
be getting away.
So anyway, so this is who I'm taking.
I'm taking of course my
family, that's four people.
I'm taking my parents, that makes six.
And I'm taking my brother and his wife
and their four children.
So there's 12 of us all together.
And we're putting together
the itinerary right now.
Now I've never traced my
family back specifically,
but I've done a little bit
of like the ancestry thing
and it kind of gets a little
murky around the 1700s.
We don't go back very far.
It seems that like both
sides of the family
come from like poor farmers
that didn't really have
any weight, you had to
be of a certain class
in order to kind of get traced back.
I'm sure I could do it if I
did a little more research,
but anyway.
Because our last name is
McLaughlin, McLaughlin
is probably what I should start saying,
we do know that McLaughlin
is a derivative of
McLaughlin.
Basically it become McLachlan,
and then we know that
McLachlan is a derivative of Lachlan,
and the Lach, 'cause you
know they would add the MC's
because there was some
sort of family dispute
or whatever.
Anyway, the Lachlan clan still exists,
still has a chief.
- A chief?
- Yeah, a chieftain,
whatever they call them.
And there's the old ruin.
Basically you've got
the old Lachlan castle
which is on a lake in Scotland,
and then you've got the new Lachlan castle
which is where the chief still lives.
- Does everybody pay dues,
I mean, it's a castle?
- It's not a homeowners association.
It's just a family.
- So is it like a castle?
- It's a hotel now.
There's like a hotel and
restaurant there I think.
But I think a lot of, the
heritage goes way back
you know, in the British Isles,
and so I think that there
are plenty of families
that still have some
sort of structure intact,
you know you've got your,
I'm so bad, I don't know.
You got your family shield
or whatever you call it.
I'm gonna know all these terms.
- You've got time to figure it out,
you're not going next
month, you're going later.
- And I'm planning the
ins and outs of what we're
going to do, but we're hope
to like meet the chief,
and I'm going to submit my
application to take his place
when he passes, so I can
live in a castle in Scotland.
- I don't think the central
air and heating is great
in those things.
- Oh, well I might have to rethink that.
- You might want to get a tour first
before you bend the knee.
- We could do the Madea marathon there.
I could bring you.
Don't know what kind of internet,
don't know if they got 5G.
But anyway.
- I'm gonna hang back.
- But that's super ambitious.
- I'm gonna let you have a family thing.
- It's a little intimidating.
- There's holes in
castle, and you squat down
and you dump in them and then
it goes down into the moat.
It just runs down the side of the castle.
That's how those things work.
- I think they have plumbing.
The reason I decided to do it is because
my oldest nephew is turning 18 this year,
and you know, he's gonna be off at college
and it's like, this is like the last time
we're all kind of living
as intact families,
to go off and take over
the Scottish countryside.
- If he partners up
and starts having kids,
that's more people you got to take.
- Yeah, not doing that.
- Got to get it over with
before they start procreating
the next generation of McLaughlin.
- I'm looking forward to that.
I want to make some memories, man.
- That's cool, I commend you on that.
You know with you taking
a vacation it means
I got to figure something out.
- Yeah you do, yeah.
- I think I just might, I don't know,
I'm thinking maybe Scotland.
I don't know, I don't
know what I'm going to do.
I do know that we're
planning a trip for Lily's
16th birthday, we said,
we had some friends
who did this every year
they have multiple kids
and they're like alright,
a kid gets to decide what they're doing,
and they have like a special trip.
I'm like for Lily's 16th, we're
gonna give her one of those
where it's like just
us, her, her mom and me,
are going to go and do a
special 16th, you know something
that she'll remember, make it special.
Anywhere she wants to go.
What's that going to be?
She wants to go to London.
I think because of all this
Dr. Who and Harry Potter
and all this stuff she's been into,
having never been there
she's always wanted to go
and experience the life of London.
Of course, so I mean
we're doing a show there,
separate from that, so I'm
gonna get my share of London
this year, and I'm gonna love it.
- After the McLaughlin's leave Scotland,
the rest of the McLaughlin's
besides my little clan,
we're sticking around
and we're driving across
the United Kingdom
countryside towards London
and then ending in London.
- Okay, you're gonna get some London too.
- So I'm gonna have to get London tips.
- Yeah, we both need
some London tips y'all.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
Lots to look forward to this year.
There's lots of other stuff
we've got in the works.
There's a big project we've
been working on for a while
that will I think in a few weeks,
we'll start teasing that
out, but we can't yet
talk about it.
But just be on the lookout for that.
- What are you looking
forward to this year?
- This is a good start to the year.
I'm feeling great about
2019, if you haven't made
your resolutions, it's not too late.
- Or don't make resolutions.
Just find things that
other people are doing
that you can look forward to.
That's what we did.
- Yeah like we did
today, it can be a movie,
it can be a little blip on your calender.
- Make a resolution, I'm
going to watch a movie
that I want to watch,
and then you'll feel good
about yourself.
- It's the little things.
- Set the bar low and jump right over it.
- Alright, also wanted to
say the video version of this
is now living on another channel,
as well as all video versions,
well all Ear Biscuits,
past, present, and future,
will be at youtube.com/earbiscuits.
So all those old interviews
from previous seasons,
all that stuff, if you
want the YouTube version
and the video version of
everything moving forward,
that's where you need to subscribe.
- And if you can't spell
biscuit like I can't,
it's biscuit.
- You can remember that
'cause it's like biscuit.
CUIT, it's like a sentence.
- It's just like the way I
remember how to spell school.
It's school, because school's not cool.
That's how I used to remember that.
- Not cool.
- School's not cool, it doesn't
have the word cool in it.
It's got the word hool in it.
School's hool.
- We have broken the seal on a new year.
We're already in it.
- There we go.
- That's good, ow, just
actually hurt myself.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist
on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous episode
of Ear Biscuits, click on
the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.